now as 2021 draws to a close i think
we're all getting ready for christmas
but i want to take a bit of an
opportunity just to talk through some of
the highlights of this year
and some of the activities and actions
that we've been taking as a council to
support our residents and businesses
now back in january we announced that
charlie park leisure center and the
sports hall there was going to be used
as part of the vaccination rollout for
coronavirus
and over the course of the year over the
following months
we supported the nhs to deliver 60 000
vaccinations from that centre and i'm
really pleased that the dart north east
alberta district council has been
recognized for its contribution to that
fantastic vaccine rollout over the
course of the year
and then in february we announced that
we were investing in our environmental
health service both in terms of helping
with the public health response to covid
but also to help us deal with issues
like fly tipping and environmental crime
and that's been a fantastic achievement
to be able to expand that service and
really get into some of those difficult
issues that we face
in our rural districts in march we have
an absolutely fantastic month in terms
of government funding for this district
firstly we have the amazing announcement
of 24.1 million pounds for clay cross as
part of the clay crosstown deal
then we also found out we'd have been
awarded 1.6 million pounds
which we've topped up with council the
council's own funding to help us deliver
external wall insulation to over 400
properties around the district and
particularly those hard to heat homes
and then finally we also received a one
million pound gram from the government
to help us improve eckington leisure
centre and make it one of the most
greenest
and most environmentally friendly
leisure centres in the whole of the
region and that works almost due for
completion and hopefully will be
reopened as a pool
very very soon now in april we elected
our 35th chairman of the council
councillor martin bakker and he launched
his
fundraising campaign for ashke hospice
care and since then he's done an
absolute
smattering of events throughout the year
and some fantastic fundraising
activities to raise vital funds for
ashgate hospice care
now in may we held some a very difficult
set of elections because of code
restrictions but fortunately they ran
very very smoothly and we had lots of
positive feedback from residents about
the whole process of voting and all the
mitigations that we put in place to help
make voting and that key part of
being a democratic country possible
during the month of may and then in june
we worked with the government to support
the kickstart scheme to help
give more young people really valuable
experience in work
now in july we signed the contract with
kilimanja parish council as part of our
1.9 million takeover and refurbishment
of the sports centre there now works
already started and i'm really looking
forward to that that centre reopening in
the next few months
and then also in the summer we had some
fantastic awards for some of our
services our health and safety team were
awarded the gold roster award and our
street scene team were also awarded an
apse award for excellent services so
well done to both of those teams
now in september we launched together
with the other districts and county
councils across derbyshire we launched
our vision derbyshire
business grants and advice to businesses
now in october we became the first
council in derbyshire to implement
mandatory cctv
for taxis and private hire vehicles now
we think that will help make both the
passengers and the drivers themselves
safer and we're really proud to have
been the first council to have done that
and also throughout october we did a
series of meet the council events and
also our armed forces covenant event to
celebrate the fantastic work of the
armed forces in november we delivered a
jobs fair in clay cross to help local
people
find local jobs and also our
environmental health team and did a
fantastic job in seizing and crushing a
vehicle
that was known to have been involved in
fly tipping in this area well done to
them
and this month december we've announced
our involvement in the queen's green
canopy scheme which involves planting
trees to help mark the queen's platinum
jubilee next year we're really excited
to be part of this amazing project
and that's just to name a few there's
plenty more on our website and on our
social media channels so please do check
them out and find out more about the
fantastic things that we've been we've
been doing throughout this year
now i know that this time at the moment
is a particularly anxious time for some
people with the concerns around the
omicron variant
and the government's move to plan b but
i think it's absolutely vital that we
all continue to work together
to follow the guidance and follow those
restrictions where necessary and also
make sure that we all get our
vaccinations done and go for our
boosters when we're called to do so we
can continue to work together and i'm
sure we can defeat
the virus and continue to enjoy a good
christmas together all the same and i
hope everyone has a fantastic christmas
and a very happy new year and look
forward to 202 when i'm sure there's a
lot more things we can do as a council
working with our residents and our
businesses and our community groups and
parish councils thank you very much
you